this is the battle of kiev
um this is the battle of kiev like in
1941. very few people know but
in in the world war two
ukraine suffered the most of all the
soviet union because our country was
captured and recaptured twice and it was
aggressed both by
by hitler on one side and stalin on the
other side uh and this now reminds the
second world war 1941 the battle of kiev
back then the whole world knew there is
a terrorist
insane man wanting to violate
poland and the whole world chose the
politics of appeasement so we've chosen
the same politics this time
and the politics of appeasement has not
worked once again and the deep concern
and all the toothless sanctions that
have been
introduced and the deep concern was
expressed the
toothless sanctions were introduced it
didn't help it didn't help putin invaded
georgia in 2008 he invaded ukraine in
2014. he invaded belarus effectively he
downed a
civilian airplane above ukraine skies
and he hasn't received a response strong
enough to stop him
here are some of the human stories i'll
just read from my phone from my friends
this is so the basement for and this is
from my apartment blocks and not
apartment blocks the residential area
where we leave it's like a block of
blocks of flights together so in one of
the homes my friend lives and he says
that he has a child who's five years old
the basement for my for my
child is now the best place of all the
concentration of children and toys there
is above
and beyond and most of all this is
basement he's never been there so after
all of the sirens and the air
and the air um alerts it's very
difficult to get her out of there all of
our neighbors in the yard are now
preparing molotov cocktails all the
drivers have donated the gasoline for it
and we are prepared to meet the russians
here
my close friends who have attended my
wedding they are in the territorial
defense units in kiev that they're armed
i haven't been in touch with them for
over 24 hours i don't know where they
are
my
my son who is three two and a half years
old here in london his godfather is in
the territorial defense unit
what they do is
they protect kiev they protect they
protect us
take your time
my family is also near sumi region where
our army is holding the line
our army and our territorial defense
units and our president are doing an
incredible job
russia planned the blitzkrieg they
wanted to take kiev and show the whole
world and the whole and all of the
russians they are
freeing russian-speaking ukrainians
but they failed they failed miserably
of course our army is
suffering huge losses
but we are fighting back
we are fighting back and we are
we are resisting and we will prevail i
will not give you the official data of
the ministry of defense of ukraine of
how how many airplanes of the russian
aviation were downed and how many tanks
were burned and how many russian
soldiers were killed that you can look
up yourself
but
what i can say is that
[Music]
there are two two ways in which the
world can help ukraine right now
this is obvious that nato troops will
not be there because this is a
direct
the
direct war with russia of nuclear powers
this is this is not what is at the table
at the moment
what can work i mean it is clear that
the sanctions introduced so far have not
worked they were too late they were too
toothless and putin doesn't care
and sanctions against putin personally
how are they going to stop him has he
been
planning to travel to the united states
has he been planning to travel to the uk
i mean
so while sanctions are important and
indispensable and i will come back to
the list of sanctions of what is
actually what can work ukraine needs
military support and when i say military
support i mean anti-tank weapons air
defense
body and by the armor because all of our
men who are volunteering now the
territorial defense units they now are
running out of it because
there is just a big influx um i have
been helping my
the people i know in in the uk who are
ukrainians who are going back to ukraine
they've started going back since
the start of the full-fledged war so the
the
cars and buses going by land um to the
polish border to cross back into ukraine
so this is valeria let me ask you
let me just ask you because i didn't
catch exactly what you said about your
family you have family here
in ukraine are you in contact with them
are you able
to make contact with them and are they
safe
i was able to make the contact with my
family who are in
near suma region they are in poltava
region on the border with
between poltava region and suma region
where you could clearly hear the the
bombings and the shellings they are safe
my husband's brother he is in the
territorial defense units they are
building blog posts and um
and other
i don't unfortunately don't know all the
terminology of what they're doing there
um but they they are seemingly safe the
last i spoke was yesterday we haven't
spoken today yet
um my friends in in kiev and the
godfather of my son they are in kiev i
haven't been able to
get a word from them in 24 hours so i
don't know
where they are and what and whether
they're safe um his wife and two
children they they have been in the
subway and bomb shelters and and they
haven't been in touch
since yesterday morning so i don't know
okay well valeria uh thank you very much
for being with us uh
and hopefully we could maybe check in
with you tomorrow and see maybe um what
is happening to your family
you can just
tell the world again that sanctions
what needs to be done right now is
freeze all central bank of russia assets
ban russia from swift ban trading with
all russian energy companies sanction
all russian banks and this must be a
blanket ban because we need to stop
putin from financing this war and if we
are still continuing all of this
cooperation with russia we are
effectively financing the war as well